some more daily gaming news for you
Resident Evil 4 remake reviews have
finally dropped and it currently has a
95 on Metacritic with a lot of hundreds
and I mean a lot of hundreds like a lot
a lot of hundreds the hundreds just keep
okay they finally stopped
there are actually only two middling
reviews from dualshockers and silicon
era and they both tend to have the
consensus that it forgot what made the
originals great which seems like a
pretty subjective stance what people
actually really like about it IGN said
the Resident Evil 4 remake is the series
is most relentlessly exciting Adventure
rebuilt refined and realized to the full
extent of its enormous potential VGC
said Resident Evil 4 is a careful
restoration of what remains one of the
most compelling action games ever made
Gamespot said it raises the ball for
what a good remake is and at the same
time preserves Resident Evil 4's Legacy
as a genre defining experience and one
of the greatest games of all time I'm so
excited to play it